there has been a lot of news lately in
Britain and in Europe about silicones
that are being used for medical implants
particularly in women's breasts when
people talk about this in the media they
keep on muddling up silicon and the
element and silicones which are the
materials that use for these implants so
it seemed sensible just to tell you what
silicones are
and silicones are a sort of plastic now
you're probably all familiar with
plastic bags like this one that my lunch
came in today and these plastic bags are
made of carbon and hydrogen and so in
here if you looked under microscope you
would see a group of carbon and hydrogen
atoms joined together to make a wiggly
chain like this with a carbon bonded
together with these extra bits here
being hydrogen so you can see there's a
carbon-carbon bonds and some hydrogen
sticking out now silicon the element
which is a crystalline material which
looks a bit silvery if you look at it is
in the same group of the periodic table
as carbon and in principle you could
make the same sort of chain with silicon
hydrogen compound but the problem is
that the bonds between two silicon atoms
are very weak and it was discovered a
number of years ago that you can make
much more stable compounds if you have a
silicon oxygen silicon bond so there's a
whole family of plastics which involve
silicon oxygen silicon bonds with the
silicon being bonded onto hydrogen or
sometimes on to carbon more usually they
have methyl groups ch3 groups attached
here so you have very stable compounds
and they're particularly useful for
medical purposes because they're
chemically very very inert they don't
react with anything as you vary the
length of the chain the materials become
more and more viscous more and more
treacly
this is silicon which is short chain and
you can see it looks rather like water
if you make a slightly longer chain it
becomes much more oily and if you have a
really long chain it becomes so viscous
look if I turn this up
slide down and put it here you can see
it only slurps very very slowly just
like treacle or it's even stickier the
silicone implants that have been used
consists of a bag made of silicone
chains that have been bonded together so
called cross-linking so that they become
a very riddle flexible but strong
material and inside it is a much more
liquid light material like that so that
they artificial breasts have a feel that
is quite similar to the natural tissue
and the problem and the scare has been
because the material that has been used
in these breasts is so-called industrial
grade now I don't know anymore than you
do about the precise nature of what
these chemicals are but I can explain to
you what industrial grade means whenever
you make a chemical it is impossible to
make it absolutely pure because there
just so many atoms you can never get rid
of the last atom of some impurity so
when you're using a chemical for a
particular application you keep the
levels of impurity low enough so that
they don't matter if you're using
something for some industrial purpose
you're using silicon as a oil for
lubricating some piece of machinery one
or two percent of something else is not
going to harm things but on the other
hand if it's going to be something that
you eat or put in your body you have to
make it very much pure so in this case
that's been in the news about a
particular batch of breast implants from
just one manufacturer they is some doubt
about which grade of silicon was used in
those implants much of the argument at
the moment goes about with the fact that
some
of these implants seem to be rupturing
that's breaking more frequently than is
normal for implants and this may be
because the outer plastic is slightly
less cross-linked than those in the
better maid breast implants so they're
not quite as strong or perhaps just the
material was not as thick as is used
normally but the chemistry behind it is
really quite simple the material that's
used is chemically very inert and is a
polymer plastic with silicon oxygen
silicon chains